welcome to this video playing mr. Boris
yeah okay four and a half out of five is
my scoring and sim that's pretty high so
the good old NIMS Oh yep
let's play my line here the rupee
headline always liked the look of this
this variation okay
Quincy - it's interesting okay that's 55
out so that efore is not possible
hmm how is it going to develop that's
very slow let's let's see
I mean look on the eight against the
King that it is really really tempting
getting getting aggressive early I asked
to miss the night somewhere so now
Knight to c6 or is there something
something better even it's not
threatening on before really
but that's a very natural so let's play
it
no not easy at all from white to keep
things somehow together in this position
what is it going to do maybe yeah maybe
even that one it looks kind of kind of
funny I'm moving again or not developing
again but maybe you you have to do
something like that okay so what now I
can just take only three which is
developing him him however what what
else is there I can I can go g5 and
Bishop f5 this kind of this kind of
thing no chief right come on let's do
that yeah it has to go to an awkward
square or allow the development here
okay so what now takes a 94 I guess I
mean or it's you can you really take on
f5 maybe you can looks kind of insane
but maybe you can takes Knight f5 takes
on f2 with double check I don't see how
this wins
okay so let's invest this move
he still in some awkward pins yeah like
95 as a threat now and then d-iii
I also threatened to take on e3 and play
94 so 95 now for the capture or I can
take immediately okay don't let's not
waste so much time if this is definitely
okay for me and I can play it quickly
avid he has rookie one actually whom is
rock d1
now that this said didn't play well it's
really not a position where he should
shoot then he he really should have
should have post my problem some some
how would you Mookie one still seems to
be okay
what can I do I have something always
allowing me to take only two I was
really expecting him
let's do that I was really expecting
would be one okay so takes on takes with
the bishop no I probably takes with this
whoops Wow hmm didn't expect that
hmm so looking porn against two pieces a
sort of an enemy's escape there I'm
pretty sure about that but you know came
it's still certainly okay for black
disposition nothing great to worry about
I would expect like Ruby ft-1 or
something where is he okay okay I will
take this pawn definitely will
that's an important point keeping the
whole queenside together it's surprised
that he just gave it up k95 queenie 7
may me
that I can play Queen c5 queen takes e5
or not queen dat XX takes no problem
what don't see one is giving away quite
some pawns maybe not the best move but
want to want to make sure I am NOT
taking too long here but trying the best
one trying to find the best one Queen
trade is certainly good for me two
bishops against rook it's quite nice the
only danger here is that I somehow lose
the a pawn and then the b-pawn gets gets
too dangerous check pre move that
yeah Camus trying to get to his 7 I
cannot really protect the pawn
yeah okay
I cannot so easily put both rooks on the
eighth eighth rank because of the back
rank mate so two bishops against the
roof that's quite nice how do you win it
down not so easy time warning and don't
have a have an idea yet
and maybe rooty five I don't really want
to want to trade rooks don't think that
this is is a good idea I'll be here to
go to Bishop e5 g3 something like that
check now that's that's actually
checkmate
it's funny checkmate that's funny I
didn't expect that to happen
yeah but I'm mostly interested in the
opening to be honest because um I really
cannot believe that this is this should
shouldn't be bad for white this thing
here yeah okay
hey computer it's giving me a win here
already almost with exactly what I
played 96 before G high of 93 and now
Bishop g7 s better if there is half
Bishop g7 mmm yeah once you look at it
that's some logic yeah intending to take
only three and then having this
discoveries against the rook the best
line according to the computer is this
with a clear edge for black but this is
this is really messy stuff so I went
here I mean this is not bad right
no it is quite okay 93 Bishop to six
Bishop e2 and no a5 I'm running to the
comp
no computer actually gives this is very
good for black ain't no age 5 again age
five age form interesting but isn't this
good I was expecting a lucrative one
here why is this bad
94 yeah this is what I planned intending
here and if he takes then cream shakes
which is a very awkward situation for
what this is attacked he cannot castle
and he is completely tied down this is a
huge initiative in fact the winning
initiative - - okay you went here and
now we got them you know what I didn't
understand why did he give away over the
pawns I was I was thinking this kind of
thing and then I know this is this type
of position this is still quite okay for
what
so it's playable you know I don't know I
mean I'm just I'm just taking everything
yeah I could have taken within my time
but this is not a bed.but move inside
and here black winning it it's not so
easy technically by the way this this
thing normally you want to keep the rock
and combine combine threats with the
bishops against f2 for example or here
after years played f3 this is already
very nice and here I'm a meeting or
winning winning huge tons of materially
but ok could have defended here much
tougher but well I would have won on
time I played it relatively quickly this
time yeah okay I hope you enjoyed it
thanks for watching